painful to every it is a heinous crime
that cannot be justified
today Saudi Arabia is carrying out
illegal things to finalize the
investigations to work with the
cooperate with the Turkish government
and to present the perpetrators to the
court and take their judgment this is
the expected thing that all governments
would do once they are see a crime
undoubtedly the cooperation today
between the Saudi and government and
Turkish government is unique and we know
that many are trying to use this painful
thing to create to drive a wedge between
Saudi Arabia and Turkey I want to send
them a message
they will not be able to do that will
not happen and we will prove to the
world that the two governments are
cooperating to see that all perpetrators
are taken to court and justice will be
seen the end this is what I can say in
addition to this Saudi Arabia has taken
steps very huge steps steps in
developing the Saudi economy in the and
the past three years and in
restructuring many institutions and
sectors today it is time to restructure
national security institutions in Saudi
Arabia in order to meet and be equal to
the rest of the institutions that have
been upgraded and developed